there's a new piece called if you're
rich you're more lucky than smart and
there's math to prove it that has been
making the rounds the last day or so and
it's very well written although it's a
little bit short on sort of like this
actual science and data backing up that
claim but it's a really interesting
topic that I want to talk about because
it's something that I've been talking
about for a long time and that's that
we like to think of our society as a
meritocracy right one where people have
what they've earned and what they
deserve because of the actions they've
taken and the decisions they've made and
their talent and their intelligence and
so on and so forth and especially if
you're a defender of sort of the
unregulated so-called free market
capitalism you want to push this idea
right that the system if it's unequal
its unequal because people have what
they deserve people have what they have
earned and it's a way to sort of
rationalize or feel better about the
insane inequality that we have in our
society that being said most reasonable
people would understand that that's not
exactly right that it doesn't really
just work out that everybody gets
exactly what they deserve and it's based
on talent or intelligence or whatever
other metric you want to point to so for
an example when you look at class
mobility right we know that upward
mobility is really low in the United
States even equally smart people with
similar parenting situations and
adjusting for other factors if you're
born poor it is much more likely that
you will end up living a life of a poor
person or a lower middle class person
than if you were to be born rich we just
know that right and it disconnects from
the distribution that we have of
intelligence or so-called talent or
industriousness or whatever factor you
want to look at but once you accept that
there's still this idea that if you do
become rich whether you started poor or
lower middle class or middle class or
upper middle class that if you end up
rich you did it again on your merits
you've worked hard or you're smart or a
combination of the two and there's now a
study from the University of Catania
in Italy which looks at the role of
chance in life success or we might say
it looks at the role of luck some people
call it or randomness we can use these
terms sort of interchangeably for our
discussion here and what sort of got
professor Alessandro platino looking at
this is that he noticed as many other
people have that there's a sort of 8020
distribution of wealth that 20% of the
people have about 80% of the wealth but
that the skills and the talent seemed to
follow a much more standard distribution
bell curve pavatt pattern so then simple
mathematics questions why it is that
that would be the case if there is not
some element of randomness right what
accounts for the concentration of wealth
in a way that separates or doesn't track
distribution of talent and intelligence
because it is really really unequal like
I gave you the 8020 number twenty
percent of people have 80 percent of the
wealth the richest 1% have about 50
percent of the world wealth and what
this study and others have found is that
increasingly the answer is luck luck
doesn't literally need to mean luck like
casino luck type of thing which I
believe is just odds of course but it
includes that elements of what we might
call luck or odds such as the timing of
when you start a business or when you
graduate with a particular degree that
puts you on a path to prosperity of
sorts there's a lot of these factors
that you don't control if you had been
born two years earlier or two years
later the same talent the same
characteristics would not have led to
the same prosperity that they might have
in the real world luck can also just be
having born to a rich family right that
that's a huge predictor of wealth were
you born to a rich family that's a
different sort of type of Locker I guess
we'd call it chance and what Professor
platino did is to run some simulations
and rerun them time and again
distributing wealth to people on the
basis of certain levels of skill
intelligence ability talent and the
factor that ended up creating the
distributions that we see in the real
world right this extreme inequality is
to add an element of randomness
which we could attribute to like I said
timing right place right time rich
parents whatever else the case may be
every time that Professor platino and
his team reran the simulation the
results differed slightly but what was
always the case was that the wealthiest
20% were not the most talented 20% and
it was so lopsided that randomness which
in the real world we call locker timing
or whatever played a huge role and it
pushed some people into the top in terms
of wealth regardless of ability and it
kept a ton of people with no shortage of
ability or intelligence or
industriousness out of being top earners
so there's no question that this one
study isn't all-encompassing it doesn't
account for every variable right but
increasingly we are learning that we
simply do not have a meritocracy as many
people think that we do and this relates
to one of the underlying principles of
my political philosophy which is where I
end up disagreeing with lots of people
on the right if you believe that there
is a direct one-to-one relationship
between effort and success or between
intelligence and success you are willing
to accept certain economic systems only
when you realize that your success
although it might seem inevitable or
obvious to you was the result of in
great part chance or timing or odds or
luck whatever word you want to use you
should if you're a reasonable person
rethink how society should be organized
and this connects to one of the most
interesting political philosophies which
is a theory of justice by John Rawls
Rawls published a theory of justice in
1971 and the brilliant thing about a
theory of justice is that it suggests if
we were to come together to figure out
how to organize society right if we said
let's meet and say forget about how
society is organized let's come up all
together on a plan we should do it from
what Rawls calls an original position
which means if I come to the table to
figure out how to organize society I
don't come in and design society
to work for me if I'm already David
Pakman the owner of an established
business with a few employees and I
already own a house right I need to
design a society that I would accept if
I were back at zero and I didn't know
what my luck of the draw would be would
I be born into a very poor family or
very rich family would I be born
somewhere with more economic
opportunities or fewer and the premise
is that if you don't know which straw
you will draw in life you're going to be
much more incentivized to actually think
about what sort of an organization makes
sense regardless of whether you're rich
or upper middle class or middle class
but for everybody it's a thought
experiment for sure Pat and I think it's
an interesting one I don't know if
you're familiar with the Rawls's theory
of justice but increasingly luck plays a
big role in success yes I am familiar
with the theory of justice and for Rawls
the solution wasn't free market or
everyone being equal it was providing a
strong social welfare system and still
allowing that upward mobility and to the
broader point you know maybe luck should
be a factor because we want to encourage
entrepreneurship we want to encourage
risk-taking but it shouldn't be the top
thing I mean intelligence how hard you
work that should rank at the top I think
yeah and actually I would argue even if
you don't have those things you should
still actually have an opportunity to
live a good life and I think that's the
flip side of it that sometimes we see
this when we say success shouldn't
depend on luck it should depend on skill
but are we saying that if you happen to
be born lacking particular skills or
predispositions to do well in certain
areas that you shouldn't have a good
life I would say absolutely not and none
of this is to say people don't earn what
they have right it's about recognizing
that doing what it takes to earn things
can work or not work based on
circumstances that are beyond your
control and we should be aware of that
when we think about how to organize our
world and part of the resistance that
people have to thinking about society
that's with this way is they don't want
to admit or maybe they don't believe or
maybe they don't know that chance plays
a huge role in where you end up in life
nobody really wants to believe that
particularly if you've done well if more
people knew that they'd be much more
willing to consider how society should
organized again if they didn't know what
they're placed within it was going to be
checkout john rawls a theory of justice
really really important document and
really nothing surprising in this study
whatsoever the video you just finished
watching was made possible by you
through the membership program you can
sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership